[Music]
i'm finally here
interviewing for my dream job after all
the training i've done i can't let this
opportunity slip
ever since i was in high school i knew i
wanted to be a software engineer
oh it works
this is so fun if i keep this up
i'll be a staff engineer at google in no
time
and so i studied non-stop in college
with my eyes set to becoming the next
jeff dean
i knew it wouldn't be easy and i would
have to get through many obstacles
[Music]
i worked day and night persevered
through hardships
with one goal in mind
uh hello hello can you hear me
is this still a good time sir oh no
worries
i might have been muted or something all
right let's get started just a little
intro my name is nikhil i work on the
cloud team i've been with the company
around three years
um can you tell me a little about
yourself and why you want to work for
this company
yeah because the only time i feel free
in my life
is when i code i may not be the smartest
person
and my whole life people have told me no
but coding was the only thing that
accepted me
it welcomes anyone with open arms
no matter who you are or where you're
from
all you need is a notepad and the world
becomes your canvas
and just like how coding shined the
light in my darkest days
and allowed me to be more open to the
world
i want to work here to help make the
world become more open
and connected
[Music]
yeah okay sure um
let's move on to the coding question
shouldn't take too long and then we'll
have some time after so you can ask me
some questions
so the question is given a binary tree
can you print the values out
in an in order fashion in order
binary tree
my favorite binary trees a data
structure where each node has two
hello sorry i think you cut off again
i'm sorry um yeah i'm here
okay so um yeah so for that question i
will perform
a simple recursive algorithm to go
through the tree in an in-order fashion
and print every note i visit
all right excellent looks good now the
next part of the question
i want you to not use recursion for the
same question
can you do it iteratively
iterative
[Music]
masaka how is that even possible
wait relax think
uh i ran out of flashbacks
no i can't even pass this phone
interview
wait i got it i'll use
silent keyboard
with my left hand i can start typing
nonsense on the shared code pad
as comments while my right hand will
silently google the answers on my ipad
and since there's no physical keyboard
it makes absolutely no
sound
[Applause]
i've won
good that looks good and what is the
time and space complexity of this
well if n is the number of nodes in the
tree then the time complexity is
o of n and the space complexity is o of
h
where h is the height of the tree and in
worst case scenario
in an unbalanced tree the height of the
tree is n
so of n would be the worst case
all right that's great um i don't think
i have any more questions for you do you
have any questions for me
yeah so um how do you become
a staff engineer
thanks for watching i hope you enjoyed
that sorry i haven't posted in a while
it's because i've been working on drama
class which is a subscription service to
get high
quality educational videos made by me on
data science and computer science and
there's new videos every week
i think i made like 60 plus videos now
i think that number keeps increasing
every week i also regularly chat
and mentor all the members who are in
the drama class community
i know a lot of people get lost in their
education you know
whether it's data science or software
engineering so which is why i created
all these classes
so that i could teach them the right way
the first class i just launched is
programming fundamentals with python i'm
very proud of it there's lots of good
content there
lots of good projects in that course and
it's the way i learned how to program
at first lastly to say thank you to all
of you people who are still watching me
after i took a long ass break
i'm going to give 15 off for the first
100 people to use the promo code
animate 2. and yeah i really hope you
like the course i really hope you enjoy
it because i put a lot of effort into it
and yeah if you have any questions email
me any feedback
please email me i would love to hear it
and that's pretty much it
alright i love you